i know self-defense i dare you to try it
i don't want to fight
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
well we were behind each other in line
at the grocery store and
it was silly
but i dropped a can of peas and he went
over to pick them up for me and
that's where it started
what can i say it was love at first
sight and
we've been together ever since
well
yes she always
has had her own way of doing things
okay
i see what's going on here honey you
don't approve of our engagement no
they're not like that i'm sorry
sweetheart yes they are like that
look at the faces
there's no point in trying to reason
with folks
who can't appreciate the differences in
others
you should be ashamed of yourselves
honey wait
i cannot believe that you would bring a
colored man into our house
[Music]
he's gone now
[Music]
would you look at that you should just
stay ahead at night i've had too much
water
at first light it isn't that far maybe
just to stay where you are back to my
place you can't escape from my embrace i
really had a very nice refill
i really need to just say i would love
to see you trust me
outside
your mind
look i really have to go you really have
to
[Music]
always comes prepared
i'm really scared i said this is not
what i want why you have to be such a i
know self defense i dare you to try it i
don't want to fight
[ __ ] tonight
[Music]
please just please go away you wanted me
to stay well i i just changed my mind i
think i'll just stay and unwind
how did this all switch
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
of rex the bone daddy ronson and teddy
12 homes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if
next to me that's the man
[Music]
elite baby
[Music]
[Music]
your face looks like a
[Music]
[Music]
the space between the button balls teen
face you tend to taint your face is
obtained
take it back no i won't take it back
big
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't need to fight over me there's
plenty
[Music]
[Music]
you know what i'm talking about right
y'all know what i'm talking about
[Applause]
free at last free at last thank god
almighty we are free at last
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
next speaker the reverend robert jones
[Applause]
how am i supposed to follow that
i can't nobody can follow that
oh
all right
good afternoon um
that that is the the best speech i've
ever heard in my entire life
ever
i have never heard a better speech
and now it is my turn to speak
huh
who put this running order together
right
you know um dr king
uh
he actually covered a lot a lot of what
i was gonna say um you know my speech is
uh uh you're gonna find this funny y'all
my speech was actually called a vision
for the future
i'm not saying that dr king copied my
speech
no no no
i'm saying i'm not saying that i'm not
saying he tried to copy it watch out
listen to him but i'm
wow you know what no come on i'm just
saying i'm just saying i'm just saying
it's a joke did i not say it like a joke
okay
nope
apparently i have six more minutes see a
red red hills of georgia he
got that out there
okay you know what all right here's
something here's something new here's
something uh brand new how okay this is
off me talking off the top of my head
here everybody uh wha
how about if we let uh black people
enslave white people for okay you know
that sounded a lot better in my head
before i said it
so that's uh
that wouldn't work
is it warm
is anybody else warm
oh
okay okay okay here's what we're gonna
do here's what we're gonna do all right
dr king talked about um uh all the races
coming together right right so what i
want every negro to do here today is
find the nearest white person and give
him a hug just just give him a hug okay
no sir you're not being attacked you're
not being attacked you're being hugged
okay everybody take it easy here okay
everybody relax you know what we don't
need 10 negroes hugging one white person
okay let's just let's you know that's
the new rule not 10 on one one on one so
just take turns and everything okay so
everybody relax okay oh my goodness sir
she doesn't need to be defended she
doesn't need to be finished she's okay
she's okay okay all right man okay
opposite is that necessary i don't think
that's necessary
man please please take it easy
we have some chain
sorry man i got nothing
all right
hold it right there
[Music]
let's see some id i wasn't even doing
anything man are you talking back to me
no i was just walking man look there is
no reason for you to get upset sir i'm
not i'm not right that's it put your
hands on your head put my hands up put
your hands on your head yes
that's your chance
[Music]
listen that can i just ask you like
politely what it is that i did i think i
was born yesterday come on man get in
the car duck your head
[Music]
all right officer i'll take it from here
[Music]
oh hi wally good to see you
he's all yours
all right
y'all have a good night all right thanks
man but where we go
i'm glad you asked
follow me
whoa
look at this place
where are we
just be patient and i'll show you but
your suit changed follow me to a place i
know where there ain't no pain ain't no
sorrow it's a place to be if your skin
is brown
i'm talking about negro town
negro town
what like atlanta
almost now be quiet while i sing
negro town you can walk the street
without getting stopped harassed or
beaten there's always a cab when you
need to get around
and they always stop in negro time
i think i'm getting it it's like a
utopia for black people yeah
but seriously
[Music]
you won't get followed when you try to
shop
[Music]
that known application can't get turned
down
you always improved in negro town
this is amazing i know right
we're going down to negro town where the
strong black men are raining down
there's light skin dark skin every
[Laughter]
[Music]
this sounds too good to be true it does
doesn't it
but can i finish the song i mean cam and
finish
i'm sorry i'm sorry
any good town you live long and well
there's no disease no sickle cell no
stupid-ass white folks touching your
hair or stealing your culture claiming
it's theirs
[Music]
[Music]
trend
by making you their token black friend
is the place where harmony is found
it's a mild black playground
talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
all right get up
let's go get up ah wait wait wait wait
wait hold on
i thought i was going to negro town
oh you are
[Music]
oh
[Music]